à la fin de sa vie dans les dernières
années de sa vie
françois mitterrand avait un bon copain
c'est georges marc benamou
jean marc benamou bonsoir c'est vrai
qu'à la fin de sa luge est très copain
avec françois mitterrand sont pas si si
le mouvement fin on s'est dit et son
confident
disons qu'on dit ça où j'étais ça et
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt ça
bien vous publié chez plon un livre qui
s'appelle jeune homme vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez
c'est commencer georges-marc je ne fais
pas pour voir si si on le fait pour soi
d'habitude dans mais je vous le dis vous
faites les autres le font par politesse
mais ça je surveille serait crucial même
les rappeurs le pont
alors quand vous lisez le rapport
gabriel de jean d'ormesson ou françois
mitterrand par l'ats jean d'ormesson du
lobby juif
vous savez que c'est vrai puisqu'il vous
l'avez dit il à employer ce mot là je le
raconte dans ce livre
dans une conversation qui situe environ
15 jours avant la conversation avec avec
jean d'ormesson
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
l'interprétation qui en avait quatre est
on peut pas en conclure que mitterrand
était antisémite
on va en parler l'interview vérité dans
les lignes ben oui le titre jeune homme
vous savez pas de quoi vous parlez de
ses références à un repas au restaurant
la mare et à paris dans le xviième vous
avec françois mitterrand danielle
mitterrand qui a d'autres d'autres
personnes que j'ai pas envie de citer
alors à une table à côté il ya papon
maurice papon donc qui ne dîne pas avec
nous il ya j'imagine pas avec vous vous
vous dites comme ça vous le vous
apercevez papon au fond de la salle et
vous dites
et dire que ce [ __ ] dinan ville
pas de réponse de l'it et rend pas de
réponse de sa femme et dire que il a mis
le même zèle à mettre des déportés dans
des trains à bordeaux que pour faire
jeter des algériens dans la seine en 61
c'est vrai un silence bien sûr c'est
vrai silence vous rajoutez heureusement
qui sera bientôt jugée et la dernière
mitterrand évidemment le scoop un peul
un peu naïve elle dit à devant vous elle
dit à mitterrand mais papon il était
très sympa avec toi du temps de
l'observatoire ont depuis la fusille du
regard évidemment pas ce que dit quand
même elle et gaffeuse maman et il se
retourne vers vous avec un air terrible
et il vous dit
vous ne savez pas de quoi vous parlez
jeune homme est donc comme vous le
raconter avec beaucoup de mépris vous
dise à la mitraille commence
et qu'est-ce qui vous dit il dit ce
qu'il a longtemps souvent répéter
cinquante ans après on ne peut pas
comprendre
cinquante ans après on ne peut pas tirer
un vieillard de son lycée ce qu'il
disait en cette scène est allé le
traîner en justice si sa réticence à
vouloir ouvrir les placards de
l'histoire et du bon on a fait les purs
à sion a été bien faite elle a été trop
fait elle a été mal faite ne résoudront
pas les plaies du passé
alors ça peut être une position chef
d'état est ce que c'est la position de
notre génération je ne crois pas mais
finalement tout le monde a dit ça et le
général de gaulle le premier de l'eau il
a laissé pape en place qui ont 61
quand il jette des arabes dans la seine
par définition c'était de gaulle le
présent dans le public
oui enfin il c'est plus compliqué il le
laisse en place à la libération
d'ailleurs indiscutablement parce que
finalement de gaulle préféré avoir des
bons préfets ou sous-préfets vichyste
que des communistes ou des résistants en
voyant ni c'était trop dangereux on les
expédiera en indochine d'ailleurs cela
donc on laisse en place la france de
vichy contrairement à ce qu'on pense au
fusil quelques stars on emprisonne
guitry etc
mais l'essentiel des élites qui a été
habile schiste pour ça que le procès
fait la mi temps est assez injuste parce
qu'il est laid parmi d'autres et c'est
moins mal tenu que les autres mais
l'essentiel de la france était à vichy
c'est ce que j'appelle l'atlantide dans
mon livre rida le concept on va y venir
alors je veux rester sur ce dîner parce
qu'à la fin de de ce dîner quand pape on
s'en va du restaurant il fait un signe
discret à mitterrand et c'est ça qui
vous a là vous comprenez d'un seul coup
la connivence qui entre ces anciens de
vichy d'une certaine façon il ya un
monde rit c'est le concept de
l'atlantide ya moins disparu à vichy le
10 juillet 40 se précipitent toute la
france les administrations ce qu'il en
reste
l'inspection des finances l'inspection
des finances on parle aujourd'hui des
inspecteurs des finances mais la vraie
naissance au pouvoir de l'inspection des
finances et vichy la préfectorale armée
en fait tout ça était à vichy alors à
partir de l'inter de vichy avec des
familles le concept de mitterrand et qui
l'emploie cette expression qui l'emploie
pour la première fois lors de ce dîner
il y avait deux catégories à vie s'il
est mal embarquée
une bien arriver mitterrand était 10 est
il un mal embarquée bien arriver dans un
accent de vérité bien arriver en 43 et
puis les mal embarquée mme à l'arrivée
cela avait été peut-être ou moins malins
ou moins moreau ou moins courageux mais
finalement c'est laisser la bourgeoisie
qui sauf qu'ils sauvent les meubles quoi
les soudards de la collaboration ils
vont crever c'est assez singulier longea
sentir vous dans votre concept
l'atlantide c'est formidable merci non
mais c'est vrai parce que c'est
exactement ça et mitterrand vous le
découvrez d'un seul coup comme la figure
centrale d'un réseau d'anciens vichyste
auquel il rend des services en aide un
honneur il faut être précis c'est pas la
figure centrale d'un réseau d'anciens
vichyste gare une souche politique qui
est à vichy et qui est un anti gaullisme
de droite il ya des relations qui se
nouent à vichy car c'est un être un
jeune homme très lent c'est finalement
très séduisant et beaucoup de gens se
raccroche à lui lui se crée des liens
mais il est pas et après guerre il
recycle un certain nombre de vichy il
n'est pas le réseau central il refuse
d'ailleurs assez courageusement ils
occupent dans l'avenir gaulliste assez
courageusement parce que pourrait rares
entrées d'un gaullisme comme chaban
delmas comme couve de murville et
finalement se blanchir il décide de
faire sa vie sans de gaulle alors dans
son cabinet il ya des anciens vichyste
mais il ya aussi georges dayan et des
résistants donc tout ça est un milieu
dans cette république paraît complexe
par rapport aux autres membres aux
autres atlante puisque j'avais
l'atlantide il visite les prisons il
leur trouve du boulot en créant
l'expliquent dans il a fait l'essentiel
cas de résistance enfin m quand même ce
que je sais ce que je pense je ne crois
pas que ce soit une fidélité idéologique
que c'est le côté bizarrement bon bon
bon gars demi mais vous dites dans votre
bouquin gier
il ya une tendresse il a une tendresse
pour ces collabos qui sont en prison ou
la menthe sa soeur qui a été au collège
léo question juive une tendresse de
celle que balzac à pour les réprouvés
d'ancien régime
alors on aime on aime imam et un hochet
qui monte à la surface c'est pire
d'essence s'occuper des autres
clermont sort des vivres aux cervicales
et serviable oui
pourquoi il a refusé toujours toute
allégeance au gaullisme par orgueil il
me dit un jour ça te phrase pleine de
vérité j'avais décidé en 45 de faire
carrière bat l'anticonformiste en fait
tout le monde se précipite vers le
gaullisme tout le monde d'aller au
guichet la différence pour exciter radon
qui sait lire où est ce que je vais
trouver ma place et c'est vrai que c'est
pas quentin est orgueilleux comme il
l'était c'est pas sa place et puis une
deuxième interprétation qui est la
mienne dans ce livre et qui fait partie
d'une conversation d'octobre 1995
c'est ce fameux rendez vous le premier
rendez vous avec de gaulle toute sa vie
il a raconté dans ça se passe en
décembre 1943 le gérant arrive par des
dix circuits d'avion absolument
impossible et il est face à de gaulle et
toute sa vie il a raconté de gaulle a
été très antipathique ça s'est très mal
passé il y avait de l'électricité dans
l'air il a voulu me faire tuer après etc
et tout ça finalement je le découvre en
avec dans une conversation avec lequel
elle pas si un certain nombre
d'historiens en attestent il l'a
beaucoup aux olives et il en a fait le
socle de sa légende rebelles à 27 ans
contre de gaulle en fait je crois qu'il
ya une vraie humiliation plus rien
debout s'est pas mal passé mais qui
mitterrand comme on dit un n'a pas été
calculé par de gaulle 1 et je crois
qu'il ya de ça ça y est la manière donc
les gaullistes on parlait de mitterrand
ce mot ceni tran huy cette manière
négligente écrasé ben oui il a dû
l'appeler mimi tran il a dû être humide
et avec jusque là jusqu'à ce que vous en
parlez tous les to les duhamel giesbert
les catherine nay état d'une opposition
frontale qui a été fondatrice de près de
beaux livres d'arriérés et je le
rappelle mais c'est ce qu'il vous a tous
raconté pendant des années et c'est vrai
qu'à un moment de sa vie il me dit vous
savez ça c'est pas si mal passé loin de
là il se doit leurs skis se mettaient en
paix avec sa conscience s qui rectifie
encore un peu d'histoire et l'appui
l'assumant rectifié parce que là la date
la durée
le fait qu'ils aient freiné ou pas
freiné enfin là et là ça a beaucoup
varié cette histoire il dit on a
rencontré ce que vous dites ont à
raconter des bêtises sur cette rencontre
parce que plus étonnant dans votre
bouquin quand même c'est quand tu parles
de vichy fait à vie alors à pétain
c'était un vieillard un peu dépassée
mais magnifique mitterrand y avait ça il
y avait ça quand il a déposé il a
persisté à déposer cette gerbe
la tombe de pétain en 92 j'ai eu cette
conversation avec lui faurecia relation
c'est pétain c'est verdun un verdun
c'est le plus grand traumatisme de
l'histoire française avec la shoah dit
est il un million
trois cent mille morts c'est ça laisse
des traces dans le pays
je lui dis mais le pétain de 40 oblitère
le pétain de verdun qui est considérable
et je crois qu'il fait partie d'une
génération c'est ça notre divergence où
il pensait que verdun c'était aussi
important que 40
il était sur la ligne que décrit henri
amouroux 40 millions de pétainistes
c'est très curieux c'est très curieux
péan raconte sa fascination de jeunes
hommes quand ils le voient pour la
première fois au casino de vichy comme
ça il ya des lettres exalté et je crois
que quand on est vieux et c'était un
vieil homme d les souvenirs du cortex
jeunes remontent à la surface mais
probablement mais c'était pas la
fidélité idéologique je ne l'étais pas
fait plus sentimental qu'idéologique
c'est sa jeunesse sa bohème les épaules
de danielle darrieux à un couvre au bord
de l'allier la [ __ ] et puis nous la
découverte du vent il songe à l'agetu
toute la france toute la france et là
sur un kilomètre carré
il parle de bousquet enfin vous parlez
de bousquet donc mitterrand regrette que
la carrière de bousquet a été brisée à
l'âge de 35 ans il regrette la façon
dont bousquet a été abattu par christian
didier tout curieux c'est curieux et
puis lobby juif donc on y arrive on
découvre que son plus grand ennemi
politique finalement contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a pu penser c'était
klarsfeld
oui merci serge j'en ai parlé avec
larsen j'ai rencontré en faisant ce
livre j'ai essayé de reconstituer ce qui
s'était passé pour moi et c'est
finalement la trame de ce livre il ya
une guerre de la mémoire
elle commence le 16 juillet 1992 au
monument du vel d'hiv c'est le 50e
anniversaire de la rafle des juifs de
paris mitterrand vient c'est la première
fois qu'un président français vient
c'est un événement énorme et il est une
aubade inter s'interpose dans un de ces
beaux discours que certains ont pu
contester
et là je crois que c'est le premier choc
c'est une manif voulu en partie par
serge klarsfeld a un objectif politique
et finalement de faire reconnaître les
responsabilités françaises dans
l'holocauste il l'écrit la digue dans 70
ce qu'on peut dire pour le
téléspectateur pour que tout le monde
suive bien
que klarsfeld connaissait le passé un
peu maréchaliste dix ans de mitterrand
et qui s'en sert comme une épée de
damoclès pour lui faire accepter
certaines choses
oui le père de clara elle n'était dans
un réseau d'ailleurs assez proche de
celui de mitterrand
et quand quand mitterrand fleuri la
tombe de pétain à l'île d'yeu ce que
faisait tous les présidents de la
république
tout le monde l'avait fait tout le monde
l'avait fait enfin le de gaulle l'art
est instituée en 67 parce que c'est le
50e anniversaire de verdun pompidou l'a
fait une fois ou deux giscard une fois
ou deux mitterrand était disons plus
acide du mal à m
alors que fait klarsfeld il oblige
mitterrand sous la pression parce qu'il
a il a des dossiers d'une certaine façon
à faire la journée commémorative de la
rafle du vel d'hiv le 16 juillet ça se
passe pas tout à fait comme ça
mitterrand s'obstine il dit puisque la
seule menace
bien sûr je les plumes est de 2,2 de
gerbe sur la tombe de pétain je la
mettrais surtout ceux les tombes de tous
les maréchaux de 14-18 et finalement la
maladresse de mitterrand ont fait que la
crise est i'll kill effectivement accède
à la demande à la première demande de
serge klarsfeld cette journée de
commémoration du sénat et allié tout
autour du 16 juillet parce que la guerre
de la mémoire elle se finit le 16
juillet 1995 trois ans plus tard et là
c'est chirac qui est président et il
fait le discours que klarsfeld attendait
que mitterrand n'a pas couché non
pendant ces trois ans il ya une vraie
guerre entre mitterrand d'une part une
partie des responsables de la communauté
juive des intellectuels à votre déjeuner
georges belmont et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est ça la phrase jeune
homme vous ne savez pas vous parler
c'est finalement la guerre de deux
générations la guerre est de 2,2 moral
et c'est ça que j'ai observé d'ailleurs
sans vouloir faire de jugement de valeur
parce que tout ça est très complexe
mais pourquoi il n'a pas accepté de
reconnaître la culpabilité de la france
dans vichy il l'a fait il avait la
position il avait une position gaulliste
puisque de gaulle avait aujourd'hui
c'est ça la france n'étaient pas fichés
l'été à l'ombre
donc ils avaient une position village il
a fait en quelques petits pas fait je
crois que les gens de cette génération
était très emmerder on peut pas ils ont
essayé ils tout le monde a essayé de
cacher ce qui s'était passé pendant 40
ans on en parle beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup depuis dix ans pendant 40 ans
on n'a pas parlé effectivement la chape
de plomb gaulliste et effectivement il
faut aussi
ne pas tomber dans le piège dans lequel
tombent parfois serge klarsfeld que par
ailleurs je respecte qui est de dire les
responsabilités de la france elles mêmes
que celles de l'allemagne
le français allemands tous à l'eau tous
des porteurs qu'il faut dire c'est que
la france avait perdu la guerre jorge
marque la différence comme ce qu'il faut
toujours bien rappeler ces cartes ont
été envahie par l'allemagne tire il est
toujours plus difficile quand on est
envahi par un parent un pays plus fort
que soi de faire ce qu'on veut un double
malentendu entre disons la france de
mitterrand et la communauté juive
pendant 40 ans on a gagné on n'a pas
parlé de l'holocauste ont à cacher on a
caché le responsabilité de la police on
a caché les responsabilités
administratives
on a caché tout ça est d'une certaine
manière il ya une vraie blessure dans la
communauté juive faut dire que la nation
elle a été amputée d'une partie de son
ses membres et ce à la france ne l'a pas
accepté ce qui fait le chagrin des juifs
je crois aussi qu'il ya un autre chagrin
qui est le chagrin de la france qui est
que l' empire la deuxième puissance
mondiale s'est effondrée comme un
château de cartes de manière
inimaginable en huit semaines deux mois
entre le 10 mai le jour de l'offensive
allemande et le 10 juillet où la
république est abolie en deux mois la
deuxième puissance mondiale s'effondre
dans la honte avec des ministres qui
partent en pleine nuit
oubliant leurs dossiers la panique
généralisée et que ce traumatisme la cet
effondrement la de la france puis
d'ailleurs ensuite la guerre d'algérie
ça ça a été en tout cas cet effondrement
une blessure terrible aussi pour la
france qui a qui a rendu possible vichy
le vel d'hiv et toutes ces saloperies et
donc ça aussi
cette blessure l'a mitterrand l'avait il
ya une forme d'orgueil à ne pas l'avouer
guillaume georges-marc pour en finir sur
le bouquin est pas le seo réaction le
lobby juif il l'entendait comment
mitterrand aussi vous disais ça c'est
clair sun c'est clair c'est que la
recette impulsion sa petite à cette
petite association très vaillante deux
fils et filles de déportés
je crois que ce mot finalement été
introduit par quelqu'un de son entourage
qui a fait une mauvaise action non pape
soit puritains mais ça on fantasme
toujours quand on dit lobby juif en
l'occurrence c'est klarsfeld
et puis un certain nombre de gens
motivés mais finalement la question de
vichy comme la question de la guerre
d'algérie comme tout ça c'est le
problème de la france bien georges
manqué beaucoup de réactions à votre
livre dans le point la semaine dernière
il y avait les bonnes pages de de votre
lit dans le point de cette semaine et à
une lettre ouverte des amis de françois
mitterrand qui disent le principal
reproche qu'on peut faire à françois
mitterrand c'est d'avoir accueilli des
gens comme georges marc benamou auprès
de lui je veut rectifier la plongée à la
pétition charasse oui à ces la pétition
charasse et pas les amis ce sens en
termes de genre oui c'est vrai qu'il a
pas de pot unités en l'adieu attali qui
a fait verbatim c'est vrai que je suis
confident un ami journaliste j'ai jamais
été conseiller spécial ministre du
budget ou médecin moi je suis un
individu lee pris ce qu'ils disent dans
leur pétition
il faut quand même dire que 10 ne sert
que personne n'a lu ce livre
cette fois ci sur le texte était prêt
avant que le livre soit imprimé donc
personne ne la lui monsieur gérard paru
dans le point la semaine dernière ils
ont peut-être lu des extraits m'enfin
ils ont lu les bonnes pages 3% le livre
et d'un livre complexe et d'un livre un
briquet d'un livre que j'ai mis des
années à écrire
ils ne l'ont pas lu mais monsieur
charasse dit partout d'ailleurs je ne
lirai pas ce livre mais c'est un chien
vous pensez pas que le fait de faire un
livre où mitterrand repart du lobby juif
ça peut réveiller l'antisémitisme en
france
non parce que je crois que j'ai fait un
livre au contraire très nuancée pour
expliquer qu'il y avait il ya eu entre
1992 et 1995 une guerre de la mémoire
entre eux est un vrai débat de haut
niveau parfois parfois tortueux je pense
que j'ai voulu montrer une complexité
française la france ça n'est pas que le
mal
la france n'est pas que le bien que nous
disait de gaulle ça n'est pas qu'une
france héroïque c'est une france plus
complexe et on voir en couverture du
point lobby juif et qu'on sait que c'est
un mode mitterrand vous pensez pas que
ça peut s'est pas tu sais pas j'ai
veillé ou accélérer l'antisémitisme
latent squelette non non je pense que
l'antisémitisme petite chose trop
sérieuse pour qu'on puisse traiter à
tord et à travers les gens d'antisémite
et c'est pas le cas de mes yeux une
brouille entre mitterrand et les
responsables de la communauté juive
à un moment donné sur une question
précise sur avec certains responsables
il faut le dire pour pas écrire une
histoire faite de langue de voir elle
est très complexe
on rallume
je leur book aller chez plon